- You stay stuck in the way
that you've been moving,
you going to keep getting what
you've been getting out of life
and that's not the way
life is meant to be lived.
It's so many things that you
go through in this game, man.
So many ebbs and flows,
so many ups and downs,
but it's the people that
truly keep going that make it.
You got to create the kind of energy
that you want in your life.
If you constantly keep creating
positive energy around you
and more positive things will come, so--
- He's an American radio
presenter and TV personality.
He's a co-host of the nationally
syndicated radio show,
The Breakfast Club.
He currently stars in and hosts
MTV2's show Uncommon Sense
with Charlamagne the God.
He's Charlamagne the God
and here's my take on his
top ten rules for success.
Also guys, as you're watching,
if you hear something
that really resonates with you,
please leave it down in the comments below
and put quotes around it, so
other people can be inspired.
Also, when you write it down,
it's much more likely to
lock in for yourself as well.
Enjoy.
(intro music)
- So, after you've been through
the good, the bad, the ugly,
what do you know for sure about life?
- That it moves on.
- Everybody says that.
- It's the truth.
- That's everybody's answer.
- It's the truth, that it
moves on and it keeps going
and guess what?
It's going to move on and keep
going with or without you.
So, you better adjust to the changes
'cause if you don't adjust to the changes
and you stay stuck in the
way that you've been moving,
you going to keep getting what
you've been getting out of life
and that's not the way
life is meant to be lived.
Life is meant to be lived--
you got to constantly evolve.
Change is the basis of growth
and growth is the basis of life.
If you're not constantly
changing, you're not growing.
If you're not growing,
then what are you doing?
You're dying.
You're not doing nothing.
So, that's why, when you
look at certain people, man,
you see them and they're
40-something years old,
they washed up.
'Cause they still trying
to live the way they were
when they were in their 20s and their 30s.
Nothing about them has grown,
nothing about them has evolved.
Their mindset hasn't grown,
their mindset hasn't evolved.
They're still hanging around
the same people they was
hanging around when they were
in their 20s doing nothing.
So guess what, if you're hanging
around the same people that
you were hanging around
in your 20s doing nothing,
guess what you're going
to be doing in your 30s.
Nothing.
So guess what you're going
to be doing in your 40s.
Nothing.
So, you got to understand, life moves on.
Father Time don't wait for nobody, man
and when it's over, it's over.
When you're 40-something years old
and you look back and you like,
"Damn. I wasted all
that time doing nothing.
Life moved on and I didn't move with it".
Now you just a washed individual.
You don't got nobody to
blame for that, but yourself.
Be yourself.
Be yourself at all times because
when you're truly yourself,
whatever you get out of life,
you will appreciate it more.
When you're truly being yourself,
you also will never be a victim
and the reason you'll never be a victim,
or you'll never practice victimology,
and the reason you'll never
practice victimology is because
you know that whatever you got,
you got 'cause you were yourself.
- [Interviewer] How do you feel about
things that happened to you in the past?
For example, you going to jail,
you getting fired from
a couple of stations.
You think that might have been
the stuff you were putting out
there that came back to you?
- Well--
- You were making some dumb decisions--
- Yeah, absolutely.
When I was getting locked
up, I didn't know no better.
I think when you know
better, you do better.
That's why I say, when I
wanted to change my life,
I changed my lifestyle.
So, I started knowing better,
so I started doing better.
As far as me getting fired,
that's just the way things are sometimes.
- How'd you come up in radio?
How'd you start with radio?
- I started off as an intern in 1998
when I was 18 years old.
I'm 32 now.
I've been doing radio for--
this'll be my 15th year in radio.
I started off as an intern when I was 18.
So, I've worked in every aspect of radio.
I've worked in the promotions department.
I worked in programming.
I was an intern for a year and a half.
This is the 7th radio
station I've worked at.
I've been fired four times.
- Okay.
- So it's like--
That's why, when I saw William,
I go, "William came back
out there to perform".
For everybody who wasn't at the show,
William was a rapper who got booed,
but he forced them to
let him perform again.
I just like the determination.
- Right.
- The never say "quit" attitude
'cause that's what you have to have.
Like I said, I've been fired four times,
I could have quit a long time ago,
but I don't have no backup plan.
I didn't go to college,
I don't have a degree.
I don't have anything
else to do, but radio.
I used to want to rap,
until I realized that rap
was just a pipe dream.
It's so many things that
you go through in this game.
So many ebbs and flows,
so many ups and downs,
but it's the people that
truly keep going that make it.
- What's your vision board look like?
So, you have--
I'm sorry go ahead,
tell me what your vision board looks like
and can you share some of
the things that are on there?
- I used to have a
traditional vision board,
where you would take things that you want
and put them up on poster board
and that's cool.
I did that when I did The Secret,
but, to me, the best vision
boards are when you write down
your long-term and short-term goals.
Write down everything that
you want to accomplish
and keep those things in your mind because
your mind is what makes
them manifest into reality.
Your thoughts really do become things.
I don't have a college
degree, or anything like that.
All I have is, back in 1998,
I said, "I want to be a Super Jock".
I said, "I want to be one of
the biggest radio personalities
on the planet".
I said, "I want to be in that
Wendy Williams, Tom Joyner,
Doug Banks, Howard Stern,
Bill O'Reilly, Rush Limbaugh.
I want to be in that number".
When they think of Charlamagne,
I want them to think of me like that.
I want to be my generation's that.
Because all of those guys,
it's the natural cause of thing
that power eventually fades
and weakens.
All of them, it's just
like the NBA or music.
It was the Magic Johnson, Larry Bird era.
Then it was the Michael Jordan era,
now it's the LeBron James era.
That's just the way things are in the game
and I knew that, eventually,
it would be my time
if I wanted that.
So, I claimed it.
So, my vision board is a
really, just a notebook,
with everything that I want in my life.
Live your truth, man.
Live your truth.
When you live your truth,
nobody can use your truth against you
and the world opens up
for an honest person.
You get back what you put out,
so if you're always
consistently being honest,
you'll get honest things
that'll come back to you.
With honesty comes positivity.
So, when you give out positive energy,
you get back positive energy.
You get back positive things.
So, that's why I always tell people,
"Let your foundation be
a foundation of honesty".
Just always live your truth.
Yeah, and even when you look on Instagram,
look at someone like Cardi B,
who is very famous on Instagram.
I feel like she was just honing a craft.
That's why, when you see
her in front of the camera,
on Love & Hip Hop, she pops.
- Right.
- She already got a natural personality,
but she knows how to operate
in front of that camera.
- Right.
- So, I think it helps,
I just don't think it
should be your only hustle.
- It can't be, right.
- I think it should be something
to cultivate your craft
and get you to a point,
but then there's always another level.
I look at a rapper, like Young M.A.
- Yeah
She got ten million views on YouTube.
Everybody loves her, but now,
you got to get to that next level.
You got to get a record
deal, if you want one.
You don't really need
one of those nowadays,
but if you want one, you
get a record deal, or--
You just got to figure out
how to really be a star.
You got to look at the goals.
You want to be on the VMAs,
you want to perform at the BET
awards, you want to win Grammys.
But the reason I made it is because
I knew exactly what I wanted to do.
See, that's the thing I see
with a lot of people nowadays.
They be confused.
They don't really have a
clear-cut, concise goal in mind.
They don't have that one thing that
they feel that they're good at,
so they don't try to master it.
I'm reading a book right now called
The Mastery by Robert Greene.
It's basically taking that
whole 10,000 hour theory.
You're not a master at something until
you've put in 10,000 hours.
- You've practiced for 10,000 hours.
- Yeah, so you got to find that one thing
to put in that time with
and everything else will sprout from it.
Radio was my thing and then I'm--
- So I was going to say,
you always knew then radio?
- Always.
People move on.
They go.
50 actually put out some great
records earlier this year.
The joint he had with Kendrick Lamar,
then he had another record.
The joint with Too Short,
I thought was dope,
but when people are off
you, they are off you.
He got his pocket of fans
that'll still support him,
but you'll never see 50 Cent selling
ten million records again.
Hell, you'll never 50 Cent
selling a million records again.
Not on one album, he
might do it as a single
and that's not a diss
to him, that's just--
- [Interviewer] That's the way hip-hop is.
- That's the way hip-hop
is, nobody cares no more.
A thug changes, love changes
and best friends become strangers.
It happens all the time,
it happens in cycles.
Everybody can't be Jay-Z.
The reason Jay-Z is Jay-Z,
but Jay-Z has been consistent.
Jay-Z dropped an album
every year since 1996.
My father was into construction,
so I used to help him out,
as far as building houses
and stuff like that,
but I didn't really start working until
I got out of jail for the first time.
When I got out of jail for the first time,
I did a year in jail
for assault and battery
with intent to kill
and the only reason I did a year,
'cause my father was
trying to teach me a lesson
'cause I was such a bad kid.
So, he was trying to teach me a lesson,
so instead of posting my
bail, he let me sit in jail
and I'm like, I don't know,
16, 17 at the time in '97.
'96, '97? Yeah.
So, when I got out of jail
is when I started saying,
"Yo, in order to change my life,
I got to change my lifestyle".
So, I didn't want to hustle no more
and I never was no big time drug dealer.
I was a quarter spoon dude.
Quarter spoons, where
I'm from, is seven grams.
You paid $250 for it, you
flip it, you make 500,
but the first jobs I started working,
I remember I got a job at
this warehouse called IAC,
Industrial Acoustics Company.
I worked there and I
worked at a flower garden
and I worked at Taco Bell, I
worked at Demo in the mall.
I worked at a telemarketing
place called Pragna Solutions
and the reason I was doing all that,
'cause I always say,
"You got to create the kind of energy
that you want in your life".
If you constantly keep creating
positive energy around you,
then more positive things will come.
So, I would be landing all these jobs.
I never was one that
let my record stop me,
my criminal record
and that's what eventually
led me to get an internship
at the radio station
'cause I was just working.
I was working two or
three jobs at one time.
At one point, I worked
at Demo in the mall,
Paragon Solutions, the
telemarketing agency
and interned at the radio station.
It's like a psychic telling you,
"Yo, you going to be rich one day".
So, you just sit around
and wait to be rich.
It don't work like that.
When you're constantly thinking
about doing positive things,
you got to actually go out there and
be working towards those goals.
That's why I told you
earlier about just going out
and working at Taco Bell,
or working at a warehouse,
just trying to create that positive energy
and production into my life.
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I made this video because
Ian Knowles asked me to.
So, if there's a famous entrepreneur
that you want me to profile next,
leave it down in the comments below
and I'll see what I can do.
I'd also love to know,
what did Charlamagne say
that had the biggest impact on you?
What clip resonated the most with you
and what are going to take
as an immediate action
after watching today's video?
Leave it down in the comments below.
I'm super curious to find out.
I also want to give a quick
shout-out to Anthony Morgan.
Anthony, thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book,
Your One Word.
I really, really, really
appreciate the support
and I hope you're enjoying the read.
So, thank you guys so much for watching.
I believe in you, I hope you
continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is.
Much love, I'll see you soon.
- I don't have all the answers.
I just have my experiences.
I'm not an expert of nothing,
I only know what I've been through
and what I've lived and things
that I've adapted to my life
that have caused me to prosper,
so I'm trying to give that to people.
I don't believe in good or bad.
I just believe in the process.
- Yes.
- I don't believe that
there's ever been anything
necessarily good that's happened to me,
I don't believe there's
anything that's been necessarily
bad that's happened to me,
it's just all part of the process.
It's this thing called The Rule of Ten.
The Rule of Ten is three
people are going to like it,
three people are not going to like it
and four people are just going
to be on the fence about it.
They're just going to remain neutral
and just wait to see what happens.
I used that whenever I
say anything in life,
or however I approach
anything, like a TV show,
or the radio show for that day,
or a statement I might make.
There's three people who
are going to agree with it,
three people are not and
four people are just going
to be on the fence about it.
So, you just have to take all
of that into consideration
and that goes into something
my father told me a long time ago.
My father said, "You're never
as good as they say you are
and you're never as bad
as they say you are".
Personally, I just don't care either way.
The only thing I can do
is be authentically me.